hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the super bear trap
atom blitz tournament it's the last day
of the blitz section it's Wesley so vs.
Fabiana cora wanna really well really
and exciting even it's a really short
game so for those of you who don't like
long videos this is going to be a real
treat and if you're wondering why my
face is a bit red well I bought this
razor here in Germany and the well it's
it's not a very good razor that's that's
all there is to it so I thought that
maybe I should wait you know for for the
red swelling to disappear but I thought
yeah it's all about the chest anyway so
just in case you were wondering so
without further ado let's check it out
Wesley opens wit Knight to f3 the red
the opening is on the board we have d5
by Caruana
III Knight to f6 and well c4 with east
sex by Caruana and now postponing the
advancement of the D pawn with Knight to
c3 Bishop to e7 and now b3 preparing to
fianchetto the dark square bishop with
castles by Wesley and now Bishop to b2
so everything you know standard stuff of
the ready
we have c5 and now come seek after Sun
d5 recapturing is well it's both popular
with the night and with the pawn Bobby
decides to capture with the night with
Knight captures on d5 and now Queen to
be one it's a known idea very very
aggressive idea the Queen already eyes
the h7 pawn maybe if Knight captures on
c3 you can also capture with the D pawn
maybe avoid the Queen trade but all you
know there are ideas like h4 you can go
Knight g5 already create some very nice
threats on the on the King side and for
a blitz game it's always useful to have
your pieces attacking your opponent's
king Knight to c6 by Fabi and now there
there are a few games that reach this
exact same position with Bishop to d3
this is a known move but with
h4 by Wesley and h4 on move 9 is a new
move so it is as of mu 9 that we have a
completely new game on our hands with b6
not interested in anything here and here
95
poses some threats here well the obvious
threat Queen captures on h7 is made you
cannot block it with this if you play g6
then just Knight captures on h7 followed
by h5 is also very nice attacking idea
it doesn't really matter if it's good or
bad it's it's a blitz game so of course
it's good alright so here but here black
just plays at 5 and the game continues
so it's not a problem just yet but after
b6 with Bishop to b5 now attacking the
knight here and we have Queen to c7
defending we have h5 by Wesley and now
comes h6 of course you don't want to
allow further pushing of the pawn and
here rook to h3 a very nice rook lift by
Wesley preparing rook to g3 to go after
the black King and you can't just attack
her with E 5 the opening up a discovery
from the bishop because the knight on d5
is hanging and if you go Knight captures
Bishop captures and then e 5 it's still
really not a problem because just Ruby
g3 and you will still have maybe some
problems here
so after this rook h3 move with Bishop
to d7 by Fabi continuing development and
now rook the g3 and remember at the
beginning of the video when I said this
was going to be a very short game well
that this is basically it here Fabi has
to go Knight to f6 this is the best move
this is the only move Fabi has but Fabi
decided to play f6 and f6 is the most
definitely not an okay move in this
position but you know feel free to pause
the video and try to find y f6 is
definitely not an okay move in this
position while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations and
figuring out why it's it's definitely
not an okay move in this position and
for those who just want to enjoy the
show
those who found Knight captures here of
course that's perfectly fine but there
is a quicker idea just rook captures on
g7 and it's it's just game over here so
what's the idea well the Queen can now
come to g6 we have King captures on g7
now comes Queen to g6 with check King
the h8 and now what do you play here
here was the win for Queen captures on
h6 it's
it's of course still a winning move but
there was the immediate Bishop to d3
it's just uh it's just a beauty you know
without even capturing the h6 pawn would
enter the game much quicker here you
don't have a good defense against Queen
to h7 mate your only move is f5 so after
we play a 5 note now you opened up this
diagonal now you just play Knight
characters on d5 with check so how do
you prevent this so not easy also the
Queen is hanging there's no way of
stopping that so you'd have to block it
but then you don't even have to capture
the Queen then just Knight captures on
a7 and there is no defense against Queen
captures on h6 mate because now tonight
covers the 8 D 8 square but it's a
police game both players were very low
on time
so Wesley just played Queen captures and
h6 first as well now it doesn't change
anything the Queen always can read
retreat to g6
which is exactly what whoo Wesley did we
have came back to h8 and now Bishop to
d3 and it was in this position that
Fabiana coronor resigned the game as
it's exactly the same as we've shown
only it was unnecessary to capture the
exponent at White's I said it was a well
it was just maybe maybe you know more
aesthetically pleasing to not capture
the h6 pawn but you know it's all the
same you're taking down Fabiana corner
so you might as well grab the h6 point
it's it's all good but here everything
is the same the capture of the h6 point
changes nothing after f5 Knight captures
on d5 and it's it's all the same the
king is in check our discovery from the
bishop you have to block this either
with e5 but that's just you know your
white can't just grab the Queen it's not
a problem
and if 94 we already said that Knight
captures on e7 ends in Queen to h6 mate
there is no good way to stop and you
could try look if 7 but they're just
prolonging the inevitable that's just
pointless so yeah after this Bishop to
d3 move father resigned the game and an
excellent victory for Wesley so I swam I
would also like to mention the standings
after three days of rapid in two days of
blitz these are the standings but this
is a before the playoffs as we do have
playoffs here so here are the standings
so after everything is said and on 11
are
and Sergey carotene share first place
with 20 out of 36 points followed by a
Vichy in third place only half a point
behind them electron lien with 1936 who
just destroyed everyone in the blade
section Anton Corbijn
was was the leader for a long time but
in the last day blitz like I said in the
previous video the Blitz was not kind to
him and if you read the leader after day
one also finishes in 6th place then
Vladislav artemius chakra manager of
Wesley so and Fabiana Caruana last with
14 out of 36 so just the vibe is just a
machine when when it comes to classical
what he just you know destroys everyone
even when Magnus is playing in
tournaments he will very often take
first place in front of Magnus but when
it comes to rapid and bliss it's just
not his you know not his cup of tea so
to say but yeah as a karakia and
arrogant after now go into playoffs well
they want in the playoffs yesterday but
if you didn't catch that we will also be
showing now again from the playoffs
to say who is finally the winner of the
super bad rapid and blitz tournament so
stay tuned we're uploading the the next
game is very soon so thank you I would
also like to thank Randy raveling for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous video series
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon with one more game from the
super bad rap in blitz tournament also
returning to the feeder Grand Prix and
of course checking up on your
suggestions so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day